welcome to this video yes it's Yardbird
again and he's back to a really good
rating 2486 chats doing the bogo again
I'm on minus 3 I wasn't fifty percent at
one moment but dropped back to that
minus three let's see the bogo with
Queenie seven that's not a line that i
have in my book but it's nevertheless
interesting let's see what we get it can
get very this can okay that's not so
sharp but it can get very sharp if white
if why this sacrificing the c-4 pond
which he did not do he didn't do that
yeah this is with capturing on d5 why it
is basically am content with a yeah
simple good position where however black
does not have much to fear my
development is solid I have no weakness
the c8 bishop is out so on I'm okay here
so yeah rook e8 not sure what the point
of this move might be mighty form it's
not not doing much yeah okay maybe okay
head still so he's trying to get to the
two to be three young
yeah my c6 night this is not not ideal
really not okay i'm taking this and go
for c6 III i drop back to a 6 not ideal
but not a problem so what exactly is
this move a 7 hangs
I can go here and then queen before
possibly but you can go to be one now
that's not leading to anything okay i'm
dropping back here yeah going from a
three and before so um before
yeah a7 is always a little bit under
pressure there's any way to to avoid it
I would like to do that
I can maybe go for the c-4 square Knight
b6 yeah determine I should have played
this this a bit quicker
Jim maybe c4 is really a big weakness
but I had to decide now quickly yeah
this is the problem really
cannot play be 5 fee unfortunately
not good really not
trying to activate my night night g5 he
has f3 ok trying to do that takes rook
takes form rook h5 counterplay ideas
can play oops that one
yeah he just is a pawn up nothing
nothing more nothing less i played this
badly the opening really was excellent
for black nothing nothing going on I
just played some imprecisely and then
got under pressure
yeah try to try to hang on here and this
was endgame try to get counter play
against before if possible but it is it
is difficult it's really just a pawn
nothing more nothing less time warning
check
try to try to be quick iam
it's not not really that is if I'm to
win this
at least I think so some King e5 maybe I
have rookie three though d6 rook where
this this is really nothing or very
little I mean he still has the porn but
it's really nothing particularly great
Jeff Jeff gras Arvind game drag not
going to try this nine seconds more now
after being worse or lost probably yeah
hmm it's really interesting around here
I really have no I should have no
problems whatsoever but how exactly do i
do I continue maybe maybe rook the aid
sorry not this rook fe8 this really
should be an okay version of the Queens
gambit exchange but i never i didn't
really managed to prove that maybe this
was right now i think this is better the
Queen has to move and maybe then I have
this kind of thing I don't know maybe
the Queen better goes back no I back is
this just looks wrong getting into the
pin oh yeah this also this move maybe
something like that if I can get this in
it really should be a totally fine like
let's say not this to see 726 the bishop
on g2 is not so well placed in the
structure so it should be okay enough to
to be equal there are interesting points
like this
and tending Queen f6 this is
questionable for white something
something like this is check it's
definitely okay for me I just need to
make sure that before b5 is it's not
coming well okay thanks for watching